alors les chéris moi franchement et la
vérité et j'ai pas peur de le dire je
trouve que c'est mérité
maintenant si c'est mérité dans le monde
salue encore vous vous dorer les deux
meilleurs temps des agents milanais mais
très intelligent là dessus vous jure on
va on à haut risque pas de long est un
autre jour il m'a dit on parle beaucoup
et il m'a dit à l'époque la la 7 e
concept part dans cette médaille-là
c'était quand on avait perdu deux jambes
à la guerre pour le pays et tout ça en
même temps on a eu hier un ballon et on
a on a comme on donne à tous les
artistes et robin et ou alors et alors
mais nos jours on a cherché d'autres
qu'on est fier qu'on mérite mais le foot
c'est tout j'ai fait bouger fait trente
ans de football et c'est là que j'ai eu
les plus beaux compliments je suis
content d'aider son tailleur n'ya pas de
problème non mais c'est vrai n'y a pas
de problème avec ça
sauf que pour moi la légion c'est ce que
c'est ce qui a été dit c'est où
ou parce que tu as tu as servi ton pays
tu es un combat ou parce que tu es
cardiology pas juste par couru derrière
un ballon et que tu as été chaplin
là c'est pas assez alors c'est vrai ça
c'est dit maintenant vous regardez les
vocables pourra regarder pour un
footballeur là ils sont tous reçu en
direct palais de l'élysée tacistes
dernièrement là il ya eu des militaires
qui ont été sauvés des otages le mérite
aussi mais j'ai pas vu de trucs en
grande pompe la fierté du pays et il a
usé du pjd à terme mais on est champion
c'est que de mémoire moi je trouve que
c'est la fierté du pays où il est de ne
pas à nos footballeurs
comment ils ont ils se sont bagarrés
jeux seront pas arrivés là julien ferret
zélande et ça fait des années que
beaucoup ont fait leur métier sont pas
arrivées la paix
et deuxièmement pardon à la légion
d'honneur
ça fait longtemps qu'ils aient un peu de
guerre enfin juste pour des souvenirs ça
fait longtemps qu'il ya plus de guerre
et ça fait un moment qu'on donne la
légion d'honneur à des artistes a bien
aux jeunes ont adhéré à ce
qu'annonçaient les mêmes arrêts à des
footballeurs ce qui représente la france
hier l'ordre national du mérite
non mais alors c'est l'un des meilleurs
aujourd'hui la vie aux téléspectateurs
alors regardez un sondage les
téléspectateurs regardent et disent la
france 80 de la loi
je peux dire à quel moment
et sinon franchement moi je suis choqué
oui je comprends pas franchement ya dix
jours les médecins y a des trucs à cenon
louis non voilà non graves tous les
jours qu'il fait une greffe fait leur
choix puis reçoit pas la légion
d'honneur c'est ou pompe tonne mérignac
où les téléspectateurs
je fais partie des 18 % qui sont pas
nationales des désaccords mais regardez
un départ d'ici là la légion d'honneur
du sommet et l'algérien être lui l'ena
convenir à tout le monde où l'annoncé
par m allez merci mesdames